إنها منهجية الجد ،
نعم ، نظرة لرؤية Amana يومًا أو
التعب واحتضان Oladipo. مندوب
موسيقي يعرف المفوض الموسيقي المنتشر في
رعب Leglock soliton الحظ لحسن الحظ في التقويم الخاص بك
منذ عام 2006
، زرعت قرية شجرة البقان آلاف الأشجار
كل عام احتفالًا ببناتهم
لكن هذا نادر في معظم أنحاء
الهند ، يُنظر إلى الفتيات على أنهن عبء في
كثير من الأحيان يؤدي إلى العنف ضدهن ،
ولكن هنا في قرية شجرة بابوان
، يحارب الناس
تحيزهم بطريقة خاصة جدًا ،
قد يكون وادي وادينا هو الجد
جاك بورتر.  فتاة عيد الميلاد ، نعم ،
تأثيرات اختيار فيرجيل مفتوحة بيتا بقلم
جوني بيركنز ،
أخذني الجد مثل بوتفارت
قلم رصاص ليديا
أرسلني جده شخصيًا
ولكل من هؤلاء الفتيات 111 شجرة
مزروعة في الثقافة الهندية
يقال إن الرقم 111 يحقق النجاح في فئته
سورات  أن ماري bTW تستخدم الواقي الذكري Carranza
Oh Sookie
ميت المسعف الغذائي التمساح أو
لحم الخنزير المشوي sammich bankabili  تاي كيشوت
[موسيقى]
كل عام تحتفل القرية
بمهرجان هندي تقليدي راكشا باندان
حيث تربط الأخوات سوارًا ملولبًا
بأخيهن مما يرمز إلى رابطة
الحماية ولكن في هذه القرية
لا يربطون الخيط
بأخيهن فحسب ، بل يربطونه أيضًا  أشجارهم
هي أي شخص على ما يرام في المرة الأخرى ما
كان يسمى حوض السباحة الذي تخطاه جو وفي
ملقة يؤوي وثيقة BTI de barranca
أيضًا غرق Botanica قدرة
ما في Osaka Mahalo de cámara
gonca لقد أتيت قبل قليل Botanica ابن
إكمال معين أخذ ماتاتا
الهبي  خطة ثلاثة جادة ويائسة
باسو تقيس قاع أو قاع أكاديمية الهوكي الخاص بها
في مذبحة مانيلا في مجرد
محل تجاري أمريكي بلسمي عسل بسيط أو تحقيق 36 مانوبريوم غير مقطوع
[موسيقى]